Hello Freak bitches.
I grew up also as a surfer,
you know,
it was grown up to growing up surfing.
And so there's definitely a pecking order and a respect there that you have to
learn,
uh,
or are you going to learn the hard way?
Um,
and,
and that's,
I think that was a good thing,
you know,
ultimately,
cause it kind of humbles you and makes you,
it makes you know your place.
Mm.
Um,
which is good.
Did you start training Jiujitsu there?
Uh,
I started,
uh,
you know,
actually,
um,
my,
one of my good buddies,
uh,
who passed away,
Paul Walker got me into a Jujitsu.
Uh,
he got me about six years ago.
Six maybe plot,
maybe more now.
Yeah.
He was like a Purple Belt Ryan or a brown belt or something.
He was a brown belt when he died.
Um,
and so,
yeah,
he,
he was,
I mean,
you know,
die hard.
I mean,
he had a place in Hawaii actually,
and he had,
uh,
he would,
he would go get Matt and he would get his place,
outfit it so he could practice at home.
Oh,
wow.
Um,
and he got me,
he got me involved.
And that's,
you know,
that's another thing that's great about,
uh,
over there.
It's like,
you really realize like obviously,
you know,
uh,
jets is like the ultimate humbling.
Yeah.
You know,
for people,
uh,
especially for,
you know,
I think for men carry a lot of ego around or carry a Lotta,
I think as men we're trying to figure out who we are,
especially when we're young.
Um,
it really calms your ego down cause you always know,
you know,
I'm going to choke some people out and people are going to choke me out.
Yeah.
And it's just no matter what level you're at,
you also get it out of your system.
Like though though,
sure.
Big Part of what men do,
they puff their chest up because they weren't prove themselves and they haven't
yet and they don't know.
And so they want to like put up this air.
Like there's some bad motherfucker because they're insecure,
they don't know.
And once you've done it a bunch of times and you know,
trained for a few years,
it just,
it all calms down.
Yeah.
At you notice like all the,
all the guys who do it consistently or the high level guys just socom.
SOCOM.
And that's actually one thing I noticed about Cameron too.
He's like,
he's a common motherfucker cause he's spends a lot of time out in the wilderness
and I think that as,
I'm a big,
uh,
you know,
with the world we live in now,
today.
Yeah,
we're,
yeah.
And we talked about,
we talked about this some,
some of the experiences,
the stressful experiences in the hard,
I mean life here is never hard.
Really the challenges we face in the regular everyday world traffic dude,
sometimes the line at Starbucks is huge.
I know that,
that's hard.
Okay.
So size tough spelled with a k.
Right.
But so I mean it puts it in perspective.
It's just kinda like what you're saying.
But yeah,
you need to experiences like that.
Just you kind of simulate those and training or,
and you know,
the Hans that I do or the races that I do,
and it keeps it in perspective so you don't get wound up over the,
the little stuff.
It's like,
no,
no biggie.
[inaudible]
okay.